il a suffi d'un pas dans la galerie des
glaces pour conquérir leur coeur j'aime
beaucoup cette pièce avec tous ces
miroirs et terrasses j'aime beaucoup les
tableaux qu'on a montré moi ce que je
préfère c'est la salle des glaces elle
est immense lac a jamais visité le
château de versailles c'est vraiment
magnifique parmi les quatre mille trois
cents collégiens des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine présent une cinquantaine
d'élèves du collège marcel robbie de
saint germain en laye dans ce théâtre
écriture ou peinture ils en apprennent
un peu plus sur les activités
artistiques de l'époque de louis xiv
une visite ludique et pédagogique ce
surtout montré la mise en place du
pouvoir absolu et versailles c'est le
symbole c'est symbolique de cette mise
en place du pouvoir
en france au xviie siècle on va essayer
d'en faire découvrir justement toutes
les oeuvres d'art à versailles donc le
mobilier les appartements du roi de
l'arène et puis peut-être leur montrer
justement les tableaux les arts
décoratifs cette initiative est portée à
travers un partenariat entre les
départements des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine avec le château de
versailles et pour catherine pégard voir
ces collégiens visiter l'édifice royal
ravive des souvenirs d'enfance je suis
venu à peu près au même âge visiter le
château de versailles avec mon école et
on n'oublie jamais ce qui m'a marqué
sans doute ce qui l'est c'est d'arriver
dans ce château immense et d'être tout
petit et évidemment quand on grandit on
pense qu'il va prendre des dimensions
plus normal et ça n'est pas vrai
maintenant que je suis au château de
versailles je sais que ça reste un très
grand château 2022 était la quatrième
édition de cet événement une première
édition s'était tenue en 2019 face au
contexte sanitaire de 2020 et de 2021 la
visite avait eu lieu en virtuel